and welcome to hannity in breaking
tonight the new inflation numbers they
are out and the numbers are a complete
disaster for our economy even as
interest rates rise the economy is still
contracting inflation is still hovering
at a four decade high a whopping eight
point three percent on a very serious
note this is an extremely dangerous
period in our country two-thirds of
american live of americans living
paycheck to paycheck it is killing the
poor it is killing the middle class it
is hurting people on fixed incomes while
incomes go down the stock market has
been plunging that means retirement
funds are getting destroyed the cost of
everything you buy in every store you go
to is continuing to spike make no
mistake economic devastation is here
with no end in sight sadly gas prices
guess what we hit another record high
today diesel also another record high
and there may soon be a diesel fuel
shortage utilities in this country
they're up a whopping 22
fuel oil is up a whopping 80 percent
used cars are up anywhere between 22 and
40 percent new cars are up over 13
and by the way when you finally find one
uh the msrp sticker shock above msrp is
going to be massive looking for a plane
ticket that's up 33
meat 14 eggs 22 percent milk 14
according to economists americans will
need to fork over over 5
200
more per household this year because of
biden inflation and over two thousand
dollars by the way every american that
drives a car they'll pay an extra two
thousand dollars on gas prices alone
already as i said two thirds of
americans live paycheck to paycheck
according to cnbc now sadly all of this
as we've been telling you could have
been prevented more than a year ago our
economy recovered from covet lockdowns
and got red red hot and biden just
continued to pump and spend federal
money even as inflation started to rise
at a very alarming rate biden pushed for
even more spending in fact as we speak
he still wants to pump trillions of more
dollars into the economy this is madness
this is insanity and that's not all
biden also restricted oil and gas
production immediately put all these
restrictions on the gas and oil industry
he killed the keystone xl pipeline by
the way we'd be taking in nine hundred
thousand thousand barrels of canadian
oil a day by now that would lower the
price of everything and by the way it
was biden the ban drilling on public
lands he closed anwar because of course
he is an adherent to the religious
climate alarmist cult that now run his
entire party because it's certainly not
him now biden then sat back did nothing
as gas prices went up and up and up
except make excuses a year ago today
biden sake yelling were all telling us
gas prices would come down that
inflation was temporary or there were
transitory they were all lying or stupid
or thinking about the economy in that
you know magical way as bloomberg was
reporting but get this now as the
economy is imploding joe biden is
rip-roaring mad because americans
they're not giving joey the credit he
thinks he deserves oh we should say
thank you for the thousand two hundred
dollar biden inflation tax the two
thousand dollar extra year we're going
to pay for gas take a look
we had an economy
on the brink of a great depression
millions of people losing their jobs
through their homes
but even more importantly losing hope
remember those long lines you'd see in a
television
people lining up in all kinds of
vehicles just to get a box of food
in their trunk
how quickly we forget
people were hurting
and what did the mega crowd want to do
forget it
forget it
god this is the united states of america
the idea
that people would have to wait in line
an hour or hour and a half to get a box
of food
in their trunk
it's just unbelievable
yeah your presidency is unbelievably
awful now while biden is worried about
getting the credit he deserves millions
of americans are now worried about how
they're going to feed their children and
i mean literally and pay their rent and
pay their mortgages as we speak a
nationwide shortage of baby formula now
is causing panic rightly so among
parents
as one new york times report reads quote
a baby formula shortage now leaves
desperate parents searching for food it
continues some parents are now driving
hours at a time in search of supplies
others are watering down formula or
rationing it hoping for an end to the
shortage i talked to a friend of mine
there try to import it from europe but
then of course it gets banned we're not
stopping the opioids and the fentanyl
but we'll stop that baby formula coming
in from europe this is an urgent crisis
the biden administration obviously
doesn't care they have no clue what to
do aboard air force one earlier today
biden's new press secretary
actually laughed when a reporter asked
about the ongoing shortage not sure
what's so funny here i'll let you decide
who's
the formula issue at the white house you
mentioned the white house as well i mean
i
at the white house i don't i i don't
know i can find out for you and get you
a person who's running point
but i don't have a personal name
i'm not sure what's so funny but
unfortunately it's not only baby formula
we could soon experience a severe
shortage nationwide as america's farmers
the people that are the heart and soul
of this country that feed all of us with
the most sophisticated technology the
the science involved in farming today
yeah they're struggling with all these
rising energy costs transportation costs
supply chain issues uh and by the way uh
they're looking at three times the the
increase in the price of fertilizer that
would be necessary by the administration
says maybe you should compost and maybe
you should use manure okay they need
fertilizer look at your screen the four
major types of fertilizer are all at
record highs look at these numbers you
like to eat i like to eat i go shopping
every week i have sticker shock every
week but look at these
up by as much as 115
by the way the farmers got to make a
living they got to raise their prices on
everything so they can keep their farms
going and fear not because today joey
actually visited a farm once again
reminded everyone that his home state of
delaware has a lot of farms take a look
one of things i want to put to rest
everybody looks to me and says
have you ever been on a farm
and i remind them that no but nobody
knows i come from the state of delaware
i represented delaware for 36 years in
the united states senate before i became
vice president
single largest industry in delaware and
the delmarva of delaware maryland
virginia peninsula that peninsula that
goes down
is agriculture it's a four billion
dollar industry
four billion dollars that whole
peninsula
and we have more chickens than there are
americans
uh more broilers
maybe maybe it's progress he wasn't
bragging that his state was a slave
state as he once did of course biden has
never worked as a farmer in the past
several decades he hasn't held any real
job outside of government and maybe just
maybe that's a big part of the problem
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else